let me know when you're ready
let me tell you something
money
is
[Applause]
[Music]
who is the best person to swim your
average middle-class unsophisticated
loser they're all americans 95
one month
you're stupid
let me say that again very gullible a
sorry god will provide god providing
[Applause]
jamaica
israel two capitals of a multi-billion
dollar industry
meet the voice on the other end of that
unrecognized number that won't stop
calling you hello
[Music]
this area is all the tourist area right
yes last year we've had over four
million visitors to the island montego
bay is the best tourist destination you
can find in the world are you trying to
tell me on tourism oh yes you can come
here
oh yes come at any time
jamaica
for most of the 1.5 million americans
who visit every year it mostly looks
like this
[Music]
tourists like these
stay at all-inclusive resorts
like this one
and do this
which leads to this
[Music]
[Music]
tourism is the backbone of jamaica's
legal economy and the resorts of montego
bay are the crown jewel
[Music]
but step outside the walls of your hotel
and it's a different story
montego bay is built in a such a strange
way where you have a mix of the very
rich bordering communities with extreme
poverty mark titus is a journalist and
former cop he knows the areas of montego
bay that don't make it into the tourist
brochures
welcome to jamaica
day three of the state of emergency
two weeks before i arrived the governor
here declared a state of emergency crime
has increased a lot frankly spurred by
gang warfare mostly organized crime the
area surrounding montego bay the tourist
paradise now has one of the highest per
capita murder rates in the world welcome
to the sun very good with an uptick in
crime in saint james what's causing much
of this violence isn't drugs or politics
it's a new hustle what are the gangs
fighting for they are fighting for loot
from lotus garden
lottery scams you're probably familiar
with some version you get a call saying
you won a lottery that you don't even
remember entering you have won yourself
7.5
million
dollars in a 2019
mercedes-benz s-class ah that's pretty
exciting
all you need to do to collect whatever
they're promising your millions your new
car your new house is to send a
processing fee
the price is fake of course but the fee
you've been content to pay generates 300
million dollars a year for jamaican
scammers
guys suddenly who didn't have anything
yesterday to the iraq rich
scamming now rivals the drug trade as a
lucrative and violent source of revenue
for jamaican gangs
[Music]
i wanted to understand what's referred
to here as the game
meet the players
see how it's played
word of wisdom enjoy jamaica the best of
jamaica
but be careful
we grew under a culture of informa for
dead that mean an informer giving
information must die
[Music]
mark warned me that it would be
difficult to get people to talk about
the game but the rise of scamming can be
measured in another popular aspect of
jamaican culture
[Music]
in a neighborhood called steertown i met
with this man
local dance hall artist exclusive
the latest entry in a growing musical
subgenre dancehall tracks
celebrate the danger easy money and fast
lifestyle associated with scamming
culture
let's talk about what's the general
theme of the song
[Music]
might not go well but there's a lot of
scamming in it i mean the word scamming
comes up a lot in the song and it's the
most no
it's a song that gets you hyped
i decide not to push it
it's enough to know that the man whose
breakout hits became a scamming anthem
doesn't want to talk about scamming
[Music]
but that same night i meet a man who
says he knows someone who can help
[Music]
which is how i wind up in a car with a
man i'll just call vee
v knows a lot about scamming but he's
skittish as hell
okay make absolutely sure we don't film
his face or anything that identifies him
he'll probably say that i am in farmer
in form of it dead in farmers get gone
shot kill them
as it turns out v wants to take me for a
little history lesson of scamming in
jamaica this complex all around us these
are all call centers for all of us for
american european companies
it all starts here in call centers
[Music]
call centers were set up on the island
to take advantage of the fact that
jamaicans speak english
and receive lower wages
but a few local entrepreneurs saw
another opportunity
the lists of names and phone numbers
used for telemarketing political
donations market research and debt
collection can also be used for scamming
these lead lists as they're called are
the backbone of the game
they're valuable and here in jamaica
they're bought and sold underground
so these are some of the places where
they're getting the contact
lists yes
after earning v's trust he tells me he
can introduce me to someone who has even
more knowledge about scamming
he leads me to an abandoned house far
from the beaches and tourists
this is how i meet tweetie
hi clegeman
i'm marianna
hi tweety nice to meet you hi
juliana nice nails
i'm greeted with weed and even stronger
rums this is what i'm drinking fire
tweety and her friend juliana not their
real names agreed to talk to me about
the game
so what would happen if they found out
who you were that you were doing this
world
of faith
in jamaica we don't play friends still
first you want our family
own family set you up jamaica is not a
plea pin by day tweety works at one of
the many resorts on the island she
wouldn't tell us which one but says she
makes in a month what tourists pay for a
one-night stay they ain't paying you
nothing
ain't giving you right going to work
it's like slavery you have to do
something else on the side so everywhere
you go is a scamming so what is it that
you do on the side though
mcallister
dominarily said
as it turns out the hospitality industry
is great preparation for scamming all
day long tweety is interacting with
mostly american clients so i basically
know how to talk to you or to get into
your head
then after hours in her free time tweety
opens up her lead list names and numbers
and addresses in the united states
americans because you have the us big
money puppy big money public big money
right no disrespect but white people
love free things no disrespect taken
tweety doesn't want to show me her lead
lists they're closely guarded here in
jamaica but after a little more rum and
smoke she and her friend juliana loosen
up
and show me her wrap hello good morning
your crash prize will wear off 3.5
million or even a car or whatever you
know another person you'd probably say
oh really i don't believe it
you're totally lying
you're probably thinking how does anyone
fall for this
but there is a definite profile of a
victim that tweety has identified some
people photographers not even not
hesitated
because they're just so lonely and
miserable husband divorced husband his
dead wife is gone whatever the case may
be so most of them
lonely are they all older people
all older people one elderly lady i took
everything that she so called her right
and she only had a one
thing that was her wedding ring that
roseman died and you know left for her
she went and she sold her ring to send
you the money
yeah to send me the money
people say it's wrong and it's not to me
it's not wrong
you send us money once you didn't
receive anything you send us money twice
he still hasn't received anything are
you crazy these people are stupid sorry
but they're stupid
brash unrepentant cold that's how tweety
sounds when talking about stealing from
lonely old people
but her posture quickly changes when she
tells me how she first got into scamming
my grandpa was sick and the surgery cost
400 000 jamaican dollars
and
he died
all he needed
was a surgery and it couldn't happen
because of money this is way less than
the money that i'm making right now
you know grow up in our church and
waiting on god to provide
i'm god in providing
i'm god for my family
i'm god
i provide
i put food on that table i did all of
that and if god don't approve of me
making something out of myself then
oh god
[Music]
with the state of emergency driving most
scammers further underground i was
grateful for the chance to meet tweety
but the crazy thing about my job is that
one minute you find yourself trying to
understand the scammer and the next
you're with the people charged with
hunting them down all right everybody
here the target is described as totally
built ground complexion will be
searching and seizing all electronic
devices laptops cell phones magic jacks
banking documents warrants we don't need
awards the target location falls within
the state of emergency he should be on
high alert just in case the target
chooses to
shoot his way out
[Music]
lottery scams have led to violence in
jamaica and caused untold damage abroad
in almost every corner of america you
can find new stories of those targeted
it's a crime that preys on the most
vulnerable and the victims often lose
their entire life
it's no secret that these cameras go
after older americans it was a great
american dream to win some money where
you could retire
their methods can be ruthless
the results tragic after being asked for
yet another 1500 more dollars to claim
his prize poland put a gun to his head
and killed himself
[Music]
as a result of awful stories like these
the u.s government has partnered with
this task force
so once you enter the community it's
already sort of a risk right right
people start making phone calls
informing their cronies the police are
on way so we have to get there as
quickly as possible
okay we're here over here
don't get out of the cart
wow
he's got his gun pointed right out the
door
[Music]
oh
they just broke into the house through
this side door right here come come come
here
hello hello hello hello
sir sir sir sir sir relax hello yeah man
sit down sit down sit down come on
camera come here
we're going to conduct a search of your
premises
we are searching for lots of scamming
paraphernalia credit cards credit card
burners those type of things
[Music]
you think this is real gold come on a
rolex
this is also a rolex you see this a lot
well yeah for large scammers yes yes
a brand new car
this is evidence that this young man
tried to destroy when the police tried
to head off was it submerging underwater
you threw it in the shower
wow so it actually has somebody's name
and you can see this whole conversation
that they had and it says welcome miss
ella
your account balance is 17 500 000
you are subjected to pay the
authorization fee totaling 120 000 as
soon as possible and they're promising
that they will receive over 17 million
dollars
lots of scammers believe in a lot of
phobia you could probably call it black
magic what we see here is a lot of cans
that they use to practice
orbia this one is actually called the
million dollar spray million dollar
spray right and if you spray it you can
make less with million dollars they
believe they believe so wow some of
these are incredible look at this one
famous double fast luck spray this one
is called bring back customers
the state of emergency led to an uptick
of arrests like these
some of the bigger players have even
been extradited to face justice in the
united states
all in all it's a tense time to be a
scammer in jamaica which isn't making it
any easier for me to meet more of them
but then i was invited to meet a local
boss
a man who runs a crew of scammers
we arranged to meet at a hillside
hideout
only a few miles from jamaica's rum
soaked resorts
[Music]
it's like a bunch of guys with masks
waiting for us
can't tell if they're armed or not but
we should probably go
hi
okay
all good
this is the microphone
as we approach the meeting spot it's
clear the boss isn't taking any chances
so we keep going this way
[Music]
[Music]
hi
yo
hi mariana what would you like me to
call you
call me victor
victor okay can i ask you what the g is
for i say it's a freemason sign but i
think it for being a gangster
so you're proud of that of course
can i put a mic on you victor
okay thank you
so these guys we're surrounded by one
two three
at least three that i can see three guys
they are my bodyguards light up they're
holding me down what guns are used to
protect ak's ar-15s
tommy guns automatic blocks my gun is a
glock 40
it's my baby
so what do you do victor
you know what i do i'm in the game
you call this can we call it the money
game how long have you been in the money
game for
more than 12 years we just left high
school we didn't have no jobs at the
time and we were getting so much trouble
so we decided to want to try something
new
do you remember the first time you did
it
oh sure on the phones i met a guy i
think his name was mike
first time he sent me like a 500
i couldn't believe it the first day of
my life in this game the amount of money
i see
since those early days victor has risen
to become what he describes as a
mid-level boss how has the state of
emergency affected you guys oh my team
of the scatter man otherwise you would
come and see about 20 guys right here
right now really
i have more than 200 people under my
organization 200 people working for
probably more no way
of course behind all the swagger is a
young man who says he grew up on the
rough side of montego bay
with very few options the most reason
why we do this is just for survival we
have such a huge history of being broke
and stuff like that
things taken from us so you know i mean
sometimes we just look at it as taking
some back
in other words reparations
the idea that scamming white people is
payback for a brutal history of slavery
and colonialism it's a justification
that i heard from tweedy as well it's
also the title of perhaps the biggest
scammer anthem of them all
[Music]
have you ever had to hurt anyone because
of scaring i never really have to take
anyone's life this coming but i really
roughed up and hurt people and stuff
like that i'm just finding a way to make
some money otherwise i'll be going out
there trying to rob somebody
i wasn't even thinking about doing it
today but i'm thinking a very nice
person
so we're thinking of taking our cameras
[Applause]
you were thinking of taking our cameras
of course
i don't know how to feel about this
it's okay marianna you're a very cool
kid i like you thank you victor
do you think there's more money being
made through by scamming than
in the drug business here of course
scammers make more money than job
leaders are like small time source if
they see us at the party they got to go
corner
they're jealous of us we bought harder
than these guys all the girls flex to us
not them we have the hardest girls man
over the next several days i meet with a
handful of other scammers
and they're all full of surprises so
first question is why these masks me
personally i'm a fan of donald you're a
fan of donald trump i think he's an
honest person whereas most u.s president
still lies i think he's
showing the true nature of america the
trump twins are actually
college-educated brothers
another woman i meet had turned to
scamming when she couldn't make enough
money as a hair stylist to raise her
four kids there's no shame in it
it's wrong but there's no shame in it
what fascinates me most are the
day-to-day details of their work every
day every day you call 284 people every
day at its heart scamming is a sales job
only a tiny percentage of calls are
going to generate cash of those people
that you call how many of them
sometimes i get like two or one
if i'm lucky i got three so volume is
key okay so it's an excel sheet and the
excel sheet is called client so there's
a nancy clarissa ronda paula alice
just saying the first names first just
first names
this is crazy so wait we're at 4500 and
i'm still scrolling
much like sales it helps to know how to
close the deal too this man who says
he's made millions scamming has a
special trip after telling his marks
that they've won a mercedes
the key for the car you you actually
send the key like a fake mercedes
yeah the best scammers are relentless
but they're also intuitive quickly
assessing what the voice on the other
line really wants most of the times
compensation something free money
everybody wants money everybody
everybody wants to drive a flashy car
guns
they like to have more people always
need more with little more than a burner
phone and some gumption scammers can
reach across oceans and wreak havoc on
the lives of ordinary people
welcome to the dark side of
globalization
[Music]
half a world away i was about to get a
glimpse of an even more lucrative type
of scamming
[Music]
while scamming in jamaica brings in
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
scamming in israel is reported to bring
in billions
i want to know how it works
what's happening
you can see him
okay everyone ready he's driving up guys
i arranged to meet with a man who was
described to me as a big player in the
scamming industry
i'm told he's made a fortune running
various investment companies
all of which specialize in financial
fraud
i was also told to be very careful
hi hello thank you so much for meeting
us i'm mariana where should it go
you have a phone i do about to have it
okay i don't want to be trucked so
you're going to turn it off just do it
to me i'll take care of it okay
i've interviewed hundreds of people
through the years
moshik was the first to ever take away
my phone
i asked him to give me the scammer store
of tel aviv
we're in the ramadan
area known as the diamond district in
buildings like this and all these
skyscrapers you see
they have hundreds and hundreds of
people that go to work each day selling
fake investments to people around the
world
in a lot of these buildings that look
completely legitimate there's actually
all this from any of the companies there
are just fake scams with a name that
makes them look real
no one knows what's going on behind
closed door is it an open secret you
seem to know do people in tel aviv and
israel know no they don't want to
attract attention they don't want
reporters calling them it's a massive
massive fraud they want to be under the
radar
[Music]
how many of these companies fraudulent
scamming companies do you think they are
israel yeah
no way
holy sh
while the lottery scam in jamaica is the
go-to con in israel it's all about the
investment scam
the depth of this fraud was first
uncovered by simona weinglas an
investigative journalist who was tipped
off by a source working at a scam
investment company he told me that there
wasn't just one company like this but
there were hundreds and they were
stealing billions of dollars it sounded
crazy it turned out to be true just like
in jamaica simona says the investment
scams in israel often start with call
centers and lead lists employees at
these seemingly legitimate companies
cold call potential clients and get them
to invest in an exciting trading
opportunity you start to trade you'll
see your account going up and up the
retention agent will keep talking to you
and getting you to put more and more
money in and then eventually when
they sense that you're not going to put
any more money in they just disappear
with the money
josh you work for a company getting
clients and lying to clients and
scamming clients yes
i found one of these agents who was
willing to talk to me if we agreed not
to reveal his identity we'll call him
josh where do you find the clients how
do you so somebody's searching a certain
thing through google like somebody is
just looking about finance we know that
this person is interested in finance so
we
catch them
they catch them with ads and websites
like this
that look like legitimate and
professional trading platforms and often
promise easy trading and profits
you
convince these people to invest with you
and then
after they give you the money that you
want you sort of disappear we actually
don't disappear we work with them for a
while we really show them the growth so
they can put more and more and more at
any point is that money actually
invested in anything or is that money no
so it's all a lot yeah
the money was never in your account to
begin with there never was an account
this company
was probably not where they said it was
josh works in one popular version of an
investment scam which is often sold as a
binary option not all binary options
trading is fraudulent and the scam
version itself runs the spectrum from
misleading investors to the outright
theft that josh and simona describe but
binary options fraud became so pervasive
that both the security and exchange
commission and the fbi were forced to
issue warnings to investors
and over the past year alone the u.s
justice department has charged at least
15 binary option agents
around the globe israeli scammers have
allegedly stolen billions
do you ever feel guilty about what you
do
yes
i i hug me sleep
my soul is like telling me fighting
against what i'm doing on my actions
on one occasion josh claims he was so
wracked by guilt at how much money he'd
already stolen from a canadian client
that he actually called the authorities
to prevent the client from transferring
any more money
and did anyone find out that you did
that no what would have happened to you
if they did uh i would have not been
sitting here right now either i will be
killed or something like that you'd be
killed yes is it that serious it is very
dangerous
he says his soul is crushed by guilt and
that he works under the threat of
violence
and yet he keeps scamming because he
keeps 10 to 15
of any money he brings in it's a huge
amount of money how many of these
companies do you think exist here in
israel now the industry has gone
underground they're not as open i hear
from people that these call centers are
still everywhere
jobs for
multilinguals in israel let's see what
shows up
looking for hardworking fluent english
speakers enthusiastic and assertive who
are looking to make a lot of money
a younger dynamic atmosphere with snacks
for the snacks alone i'm going to send
an email to this one
so apart from people like you who's
benefiting from this i know there are a
lot of mafias involved in this from
georgia russia israel of course
hi this is maria flores
yes maria flores i emailed about a job
position
if i wanted to go to one of these
companies and
film undercover inside and say that i'm
applying for a job what should i say
while you're applying something maybe
so i've got my little button camera
right here
i've got the mic pack all right let's
roll on it
while applying for jobs at what i
suspect might be a scam investment
company i've turned to josh for advice
on how to get my foot in the door you
can say that i know how to do sales and
probably you can get it not in the
actual trading no there's agents who
don't know
anything single word about trading you
just know how to sell i worked in
translations as an interpreter i also
worked at a carpet rugs company where i
was dealing with very rich clients
[Music]
should i be concerned about my security
if they find out on filming under
recovery yes
what do you think they could do there
are no limits what what about worst
damage you think you can you can get off
i mean if i i could be hurt or killed
exactly so that's it that's the answer
for your questions
have we thought this through guys
this for better or worse is where my
curiosity gets the better of me
what could these places possibly look
like from the inside
there's only one way to find out
so maria flores i was born in 87 i'm
moving to tel aviv with my boyfriend
which is jacob he's israeli i'm applying
for a sales job at this company you're
my friend and you're helping me with
hebrew yeah sounds good yeah
my wing woman for this operation is an
amazing local producer
whose name and identity we've agreed not
to disclose so i've got my little button
camera right here i've got the mic pack
this gets really hot so i don't want to
turn it on early
yep definitely nervous just can't wait
for this to be over so you're constantly
thinking that maybe they're going to
realize that you're filming even though
they probably aren't
all right let's roll on it
you see it yeah okay so it's recording
now wish me luck guys
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
this is it
okay so we're here
it sounds like there's a party going on
in there right yeah there's music in it
hi how are you i'm here to meet you i am
oh you're waiting for me
hi how are you nice to meet you
this is the man i had corresponded with
over email this is a nice office
[Music]
we can't know for sure that this is a
scam company but our sources told us to
be on the lookout for certain clues like
a blind emphasis on sales and assurances
that no knowledge of finance is required
obviously sales
oh definitely that's where you come from
right you come from sales yeah
my only fear is that i don't know
anything about the forex market most of
my guys here didn't have any
qualifications
or financial industry really okay so
it's not that hard
so what are you looking for what kind of
characteristics would you want to make a
lot of money that's very important great
so all i need is to want money okay
then the manager arrives hi
nice to meet you too and get straight to
the point
you're working for a platform
okay people here are making
up to 150 000 per month wait how much
how much money can i make here you want
it in your store it can be up to thirty
thousand dollars a month
okay
not bad for an entry-level job
again it's hard to say for certain that
this is a scam company but for an
investment firm they sure have a funny
approach to customer service it's
important for me to tell you right now
because i don't want you to have a
wrong idea about this place you don't
care if the client is making money or
losing money
you just want them to trade okay this is
how the system is making money
okay i will tell you from now on there
are two things that you're going let's
say to lie about them okay first of all
your location
uh and your
personal name
sales people at scam companies are
ordered to sell under fake names
they're also told to lie about the
company's location
the scammers say they're new york london
zurich
but never ever israel
if you don't know who you're dealing
with or where they're located it's very
hard to get your money back
he kept looking at my boobs can you
believe it i was thinking are they
looking at my boobs or the camera or my
necklaces or what's happening
okay guys okay the good news is that i
was hired
i can start as early as next week nice
i mean super shady i'm so happy it's
over
as we drive through tel aviv i realize
the city skyline provides the perfect
white collar camouflage
so much of the business world looks and
sounds the same
the offices the branding the button
downs
and yet some not small number of these
normal looking people are on their way
to normal looking cubicles where they'll
spend their days stealing money from
innocent people around the world
and for what
so they can buy
a big ass yacht
[Music]
on my last day in tel aviv i caught up
with moshiko to try and understand how
he justifies the lifestyle he's chosen
[Music]
i thought people wire me half a million
dollars
and in three months i might send them
back to 30 000 and they think they've
had a bad experience with financial
markets there's no part of you that
feels bad about this
you're taking away the last 200 000 from
joe the mechanic who's worked all his
life for this month joe the mechanic
thinks it's responsible to send 200 000
to a website that he hasn't checked out
joe the mechanic needs to be responsible
for his decisions
so moshiko you seem like a very smart
person who's obviously has no problem
making money why do why do it this way
well can you make a million dollars in a
week from home
come on
you live one life why should i spend my
whole life working making 50 000 a year
when i can sit here and i can enjoy my
life how much money do you think you've
made from this most i made in one day
was three hundred thousand dollars
ten plus years i have probably brought
in 75 to 100 million dollars
mushiko says that scamming is here to
stay it's an inconvenient truth about
the globalized worlds just like pc
barnum said what's uh there's a sucker
born every minute
you know who else said that to us the
jamaican scammer the exact same line
that's absolutely true
[Music]
hello hey adam
uh-huh brace yourself
are you embraced
you've won
19.42
million us dollars how'd you feel
okay how is that possible adam do you
eat out
yeah are you vegetarian
uh-huh oh my god adam you ran your
credit card at a whole food store have
you had whole foods recently yeah all
the time adam you've won you
won what are you gonna do with 19.42
million dollars
hey adam if you're watching i want you
to know that this call is a scam out of
the sucker
adam you're not a sucker but the guys on
the other line are hoping really hoping
that you are i would be shocked to i
don't never want anything man are you so
lucky they make a living in a way that's
obviously wrong
but imagine waking up every morning
and seeing a bunch of tourists spending
more money in a week than you make in a
year
and then going home to a place outside
resort walls
that were erected to keep you out
historically i don't think about the
scales
now imagine all this is wrapped in a
history of slavery and exploitation a
legacy that is very much alive and well
there's been no compensation for
colonialism in the 400 years of survivor
it's reverse imperialism reverse
imperialism yeah we're taking resources
that are readily available most youth
are unemployed if you have a phony of a
chance
if you have a phone
you have a chance
it's the most powerful rationalization
i've heard
phone scamming as a last resort
a literal lifeline
[Music]
even so
most scammers i met seemed to struggle
with what they do
jungle out here
[Music]
i know tweety
[Music]
does almost there and almost here
good spider web
[Music]
just down here yeah
you good
this is really cool
yeah
so you're in jamaica you have black
magic everywhere
we believe in wash-offs so we are
washing off the crust is the bad look
so this is to ward off the evil spirits
right we call them black people you guys
say ghost right ghost yeah and you mix
that with water okay
[Music]
well it's getting worse
wow it's raining it's raining a lot
i'm gonna join you since i'm totally wet
already anyway there's no point in me
pretending
here i've spent a lot of time with
people like tweedy telling stories of
those who make a living on the wrong
side of the law
all too often the people who inhabit
these worlds are painted as ruthless
criminals
immoral villains
bad people
but in my experience they are a lot more
like us than we want to admit some
people are very hard
some people have it easy
it's all life is
new beginning
everything is a scam everybody takes
their piece who's making money off of
these industries
everyone you fund entire countries what
will make you stop doing this if i'm a
billionaire
i'll be done
[Music]
no it's too much fun how do you think
this is going to end for you
that's
that's it it's life
[Music]
you